digamos que tienes una prueba de
colesterol y que de alguna forma ya sea
mágica o no tan mágica tú sabes que la
probabilidad de que la prueba sea
correcta es de 99%
ok tienes una probabilidad de 99% de que
la prueba de colesterol sea correcta
cada vez que haces la prueba y eso es
algo que sabes entonces podemos pensar
que estamos suponiendo lo pero bueno el
chiste es que tú traes a 100 personas a
un cuarto y les vas a aplicar esta
prueba entonces estamos aplicando la
prueba de colesterol 100 veces a veces
entonces cuáles son los posibles
resultados que podemos obtener será que
de las 100 veces que aplicamos la prueba
exactamente 99 van a estar correctas y
una de las pruebas va a estar mal pues
no esté 99% es simplemente la
probabilidad de que cada una de las
pruebas
de bien o esté mal pero esto para nada
significa que si aplicamos 100 pruebas
99 de ellas van a ser correctas y una no
aunque puede ser que todas las pruebas
estén bien puede ser que 98 de las
pruebas estén bien y 2 estén mal y bueno
puede pasar un montón de cosas pero lo
que sí sabemos es con qué probabilidad
sucede cada uno de esos escenarios y
esas probabilidades pues me adelanté un
poco y ya sea que estas probabilidades y
las vamos a ver ahorita y bueno el punto
de este vídeo no es calcular las
probabilidades que voy a poner ahorita
pero si te interesa repasar cómo se
calculan y repasar la combinatoria y
todo lo que hacemos para calcular las
puedes buscar esos vídeos en la página
de khan academy pero bueno como dije ya
tengo todas las probabilidades
calculadas tenemos que la probabilidad
de que la prueba sea correcta
correcta 100
de las 100 veces que hicimos la prueba
tenemos una prueba que en cada uno de
los intentos que hacemos tiene una
probabilidad del 99 por ciento de ser
correcta hacemos esa prueba 100 veces y
aquí me estoy preguntando cuál es la
probabilidad de que la prueba sea
correcta todas las 100 veces que hacemos
el experimento aunque todas las 100
veces que hacemos la prueba y ya calculé
esta probabilidad y es igual a 36 puntos
6 % y bueno estoy redondeando al primer
decimal ahora aquí esto lo que nos dice
es que la probabilidad de que la prueba
sea correcta las 100 veces que aplicamos
la prueba es mayor a un tercio lo cual
es bastante alto aunque entonces no
sería nada raro que los 100 resultados
de la prueba fueran correctos y podemos
seguir escribiendo las probabilidades
tenemos que la probabilidad de que la
prueba sea correcta y para no estar
escribiendo
todo el tiempo voy a poner aquí nada más
unas comillas pero la probabilidad de
que la prueba sea correcta 99 de las 100
veces que hacemos la prueba
37.0 por ciento y esto es lo que
podríamos esperar que todas las pruebas
sean correctas también tiene una
probabilidad bastante alta pero aún así
la probabilidad de que exactamente 99 de
las siempre va sean correctas tiene un
poquito más de probabilidad pero bueno
podemos seguir sacando probabilidades la
probabilidad de que sea correcta 98 de
las 100 veces que hacemos la prueba
18.5 por ciento y bueno voy a seguir
escribiendo unas cuantas probabilidades
más la probabilidad de que la prueba sea
correcta exactamente 97 de las 100 veces
que la aplicamos o sea que tres de esas
veces es incorrecta esta probabilidad es
igual a 6% porque definitivamente es
mucho menos probable que estos
escenarios pero sigue estando dentro de
lo que puede llegar a suceder y la
probabilidad de que la prueba sea
correcta 96 de las 100 veces
es aproximadamente 1.5 por ciento y
bueno voy a hacer una última aunque
bueno podríamos seguir calculando
probabilidades de todos los escenarios
pero bueno la probabilidad de que la
prueba sea correcta 95 de las 100 veces
0.3 por ciento pero bueno ver estas
probabilidades me parece que fue un muy
buen experimento si tenemos una prueba
que es correcta con una probabilidad de
99 por ciento y aplicamos esa prueba
cien veces entonces aquí tenemos la
probabilidad de que esa prueba sea
correcta todas las veces que le
apliquemos o que esa prueba se equivoque
una sola vez o que se equivoque dos
veces y así pero bueno
ahora vamos a empezar a pensar acerca de
las pruebas de hipótesis
tomando en cuenta esto que acabamos de
ver pero bueno siguiendo con esto
digamos que tú tienes una nueva prueba
de colesterol nueva
prueba de colesterol y pues no sabes qué
tan probable es que esta prueba sea
correcta pero lo que sí sabes es que
para que el gobierno o bueno cualquier
regulación apruebe que salga al mercado
tu prueba de colesterol necesitas que la
probabilidad de que ésta sea correcta
sea por lo menos 99 por ciento aunque
entonces necesitas
necesitas tener
una probabilidad de que la prueba sea
correcta correcta de 99% por crear pero
pone atención en que tú no sabes qué
sucede esto aunque esto es lo que tú
necesitas que suceda y entonces tú
fórmula es una hipótesis hipótesis
y cuando veas un poco más de estadística
va a saber que hay hipótesis nulas e
hipótesis alternas pero por el momento
esto es simplemente una hipótesis y tu
hipótesis dice que la probabilidad de
que la nueva prueba nueva prueba sea
correcta correcta la probabilidad de que
tu pruebas sea correcta y por lo tanto
la puedas usar tu hipótesis dice que
esta probabilidad es del 99% entonces
para ver si tu hipótesis está bien o no
lo que hace es aplicar 100 veces tu
nueva prueba y aplicar
nueva prueba
100 meses a white tú todavía no sabes
cuál es la probabilidad de que sea
correcta pero por eso la estamos
aplicando cien veces para ver más o
menos cómo anda la prueba así es que
aplicas la nueva prueba 100 veces y de
esas 100 veces tú sabes y bueno para
saber utilizas alguna otra prueba de
colesterol que sea buenísima que no
tengas lugar a duda pero resulta que de
las 100 veces que aplicaste la nueva
prueba dio un resultado correcto estuvo
correcta 95 de esas 100 veces que la
aplicamos entonces ya que sucedió esto
tú te sientes cómodo con esta hipótesis
y la pregunta que nos tenemos que hacer
es aceptamos esta hipótesis o no y lo
que hacemos es preguntarnos si esta
hipótesis fuera correcta si la
probabilidad de que la nueva prueba sea
correcta es 99 por ciento entonces cuál
es la probabilidad
este resultado y aquí es donde
recordamos este lado de la pantalla que
si la hipótesis es cierta y la nueva
prueba tiene una probabilidad de ser
correcta de 99 por ciento como aquí
entonces la probabilidad de que si
aplicamos 100 veces la prueba 95 de esas
veces sean correcta y la sota cinco
veces no es de 0.3 por ciento así es que
si suponemos que la hipótesis es cierta
y suponemos que la hipótesis es cierta
entonces la probabilidad de los
resultados observados es de 0.3 por
ciento la probabilidad de los resultados
observados
0.3 por ciento
aproximadamente y bueno dado este
resultado lo más sensato sería rechazar
esta hipótesis porque pues si puede ser
que nos haya tocado súper mala suerte y
que por eso sólo 95 de las 100 pruebas
hayan sido correctas pero si no esta
hipótesis es cierta entonces la
probabilidad de que nos haya tocado tan
mala suerte es demasiado pequeña es 0.3
por ciento y bueno
más adelante en estadística vamos a ver
como hay ciertos umbrales que utilizan
las personas para determinar si se
aprueba una hipótesis o si se rechaza lo
vamos a ver más adelante pero por el
momento tener una probabilidad tan baja
de observar el resultado del experimento
nos está indicando que esta hipótesis
seguramente está mal tenemos que
rechazar esta hipótesis aunque nuestra
nueva prueba de colesterol resultó no
ser tan buena como necesitamos que lo
sea